natasha you're not just despite  but an avenger  i couldn't be more proud of you you  smell really bad  on july 9. what brings you home we have  unfinished business  the experience still fits  will be worth the wait  let's go marvel studios black widow  windy pg-13  tickets and pre-orders available now  july 9th  okay let's go  [Applause]  marvel studios black widow ready pg-13  tickets and pre-orders available now  experience it  july 9. and now the moment you've all  been waiting for  marvel studios black widow enjoy this  special look  i've lived a lot of lives but i'm done  running from my past  [Music]  there was an assassin spy  an avenger before that  i had a family on july 9th  we have unfinished business we fight  with you  the wait  is over  you okay great plan  [Music]  i love the part where i almost bled to  death  marvel studios black widow raided pg-13  experience it july 9.  you